Nập ủng đối thị bất là bài bọn khó của hành đổi bối khi mưa lưỡng kéo dài.
Để giảm áp lực cho hẹt thống thất nước,
cú đô đăng trên khai rạc dự án chống gập khẩn cấp,
bối tổng ủng đình gần 6 nghìn sấu chăm tỷ đầu,
dự kiến hoàn thành trước bộ bừa đầm này.
Cái tạo hạt liều xong kiêm liều,
lối xong tô lịch, bối trạm bước ím sờ,
dự án gồm nọ vét kèm và xây hẹt thống cấu kết nối,
khi vọng giảm gập cho cú gực biến nằm lộ đồ,
tổ vốn cân bệ trăm tỷ đầu, dự kiến hoàn thành trong quy ba.
Cái tạo kênh thủy cơm để bộ cấp nước cho xong tô lịch,
tăng giòn chảy cải tiệp ô nhiễm và giảm ủng gập cho các thiệu lưu vực như echo home,
bàn ngoại giao, tay hồ tay, xí pù tra,
tổng mức đầu tư khoảng 8, sau mới chiến tỷ đầu,
dự kiến xong trong quy hai.
Nên công xuất trạm bơm và xây cống giọc bệ lộ thang lòng,
tăng khả năng piêu thoát nước cho các cú đồ thị hai bên tuyến,
dự án vinh 1,6 mươi tỷ đầu, dự kiến hoàn thành trước 8 mươi thần tư.
Bộ xuống trạm bơm và bệ điều kết cú vực xong tô lịch,
tảy về, nhằm giảm áp lực cho hệ thống xong hiệp hiếu,
dự án có vốn nằm chăm chỉ mươi tỷ đầu, dự kiến hoàn thành trong quy hai.
Sông xong quy đó, hà nội cũng đẩy mạnh sư dựa các khổ điều thoát để chia lửa cho hệ thống thóc nước đồ thị,
dự hồ điều hoàn phút đồ ở phần từ liêm,
quy mô 8 mươi sấu phẩy mạnh biệt sấu hệ thà,
bốn đầu tư tảm chăm chỉ đồng.
Hồ đầu mối mấy chi ở phần đại mốt, dựa khoảng 12 hích thà,
tổng đồ thưa 8 chăm mạnh biệt tỷ đầu,
và hồ điều hoàn in những một ở xã ăn khánh,
quy mô khoảng 12 hích thà, bốn đầu tư tảm chăm 5 mươi thám khi đồng.